e la tt ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
video sono fa vj ed oggi va beh posso
spiegare non è che sto guardando dei
porno gay
in pratica ragazzi bisogna indovinare
quale tra le due cose che il sito ci
darà quali tra le due cose è la più
famosa è il metro di misura per capire
quali tra le due cose la più popolare
vince quale delle due è la più googlata
cioè la più cercata su google
facciamo play game ragazzi che vedere
sto tizio ancora per un po potrei
sboccare per terra partiamo con qual è
il più googlato tra martin luther king e
nike martin luther king a 823 mila
ricerche al mese mi chiama i che secondo
me di più quindi più fanno vado a 11
milioni
porca [ __ ] stravinto nike nike e iphone
6 ass
dai che è stata cercata 11 milioni di
volte
secondo me più famoso l'iphone porca
fontana tra nove milioni e 11 milioni ma
dio mio ma che ne so a quale più famoso
tra xbox one 4 milioni di ricerche al
mese e nicki minaj
secondo me i ragazzi sono il culo di
nicki minaj e più googlato dell'xbox
quindi aiger grande enichem in altra
nicki minaj children in need nome nicki
minaj anche se children in need
meriterebbe di 90.000 children in need
tra children in need e liposuzione per
che bella immagine liposuzione
sicuramente più famosa the children in
need è infatti tra liposuzione e gli
abba cult ragazzi qualcuno vuole
contestare la chioma di
vabbè comunque gli abba credo gli abbia
poi oddio non so 673 ho vinto ragazzi
siamo arrivati a quattro di fila
punteggio epico tra netflix e gli abba
ovviamente netflix quasi convinto porca
[ __ ] quanto hanno cercato netflix 55
milioni di ricerche nell'ultimo mese
netflix e cile bear credo nel flics
quasi sicuramente ma dopo la cisl ei
bond batman batman 3 milioni e mezzo tra
batman e la budweiser io non bevo la
birra non sono capace di fare queste
cose meno [ __ ] essere astemio e
servito nella vita maledizione siamo
otto di fila non lo sa anche come si
pronuncia stabilirla brott la budweiser
e sideways questo è difficile secondo me
non posso barare andare a guardare non
lo so ragazzi dell'abe meno si fosseri
cagliari solo stessa e quindi merda se
azzecco questa arriviamo a dieci ragazzi
tra segue e ci hotel 5 stelle hotel 5
stelle secondo me ne ha di più arcani
quella migliorata gli hotel a cinque
stelle la prossima volta made in emilia
romagna in vacanza impongano prove di
ragazzi stava arrivando a dieci ne
mancava una per arrivare a dieci ragazzi
dobbiamo arrivare a 10 non me ne frega
niente devo arrivare a 10 lei a game ce
la possiamo fare dobbiamo arrivare a 10
tra bidello e sessismo sessismo
grazie a dio la gente si documenta tra
sessismo e matri solo perché ho fatto la
foto con il protagonista di matrix
nell'ultimo mese secondo me matrix vince
sbagliato a cliccare questo segno del
destino
significa che doveva andare di giu
grazie destino tra metrics m dense io
non ho mai giocato in vita mia
però sicuramente lui ma dopo madonna mia
quanto via toros solitario ma dio mio
c'è ancora qualcuno che se lo caga sto
coso e penso meno ma che vita vuota cia
la gente santo iddio asso 4
3 3 con gioco di di nardo si è
esattamente la scimmia rappresenta a me
in questo istante perfetto clash of
classe mini cooper clash of class quanto
già santo dio clash of lance per forza
evert mi chiama vorremmo ma vuoi mettere
la mini cooper facepalm mini cooper
minchia però facepalm se la gioca tra
face wallner las vegas las vegas
sicurissimo perfetto ragazzi netflix è
stata più cercate in assoluto nella vita
vorrei dire las vegas e i phone 7 iphone
6 s era un milione qualcosa quindi
secondo me i phone 7 gesù ti ringrazio
glen strambo rift planes tamburi huawei
budweiser questo è iphone set iphone set
ecco e fare non solo cari non so ma come
siccome si pronuncia tra glen quello lì
e ai e lionel messi ajo nel mese
ovviamente perfetto tra lionel messi è
l'ultima cena
lionel messi era era se la cava è
l'ultima cena però non pensavo tra
l'ultima cena e conver
anche le converse da quando mi sono
fatto le scarpe personalizzate a venice
beach hanno preso i big likes mini vado
su converse che vince sicuro questa
volta il destino non mi fotte perché è
giusto ma perché io so ai numeri delle
cose quindi capisco un albo me l'hai
detto frimm budillon mi cordon ecco non
fumo non bevo però porca di quella
[ __ ] ciò l'alzheimer non mi ricordo
quante ramar boro ragazzi verrà di più
di un di meno
era di meno e ora di meno che culo non
mi ricordavo mai o ragazzi sembra 96
azzecco questo ho vinto tram al boro e
machu picchu meno
ma che cazzo sono il caio il machu
picchu dai madama baffa in culo ma non
sono anche scrivere massima ho capito ma
vi pare che sta roba è più cercata del
delle malboro che è molto più bello e
molto più salutare sicuro ma come fa
tutti gli fa morire la famiglia nel
machu picchu che cazzo fa per te è un
punteggio fantastico se nella top dei 10
per cento dei giocatori e la madonna
solo al 10 per cento dei giocatori
arriva fino a arriva fino a 9 dai
ragazzi riproviamoci devo arrivare a 10
ormai sono puntato su sto 10 la back to
the futureheads virgin atlantic e tutte
e due le cose sono fantastiche quindi
devo capire back to the fiducia non so
ma che culo per niente che buco di culo
tra ufo e virgin atlantic ufo per forza
traccia il mare je so cosa ho detto e
couscous il ku kux klan non so neanche
come non sarà anche dirlo è sicuramente
books line perché miglia non dopo questo
può regolarsi e megan fox e va bene
allora mela me ma servi così megan fox è
ovvio con tutti questi si ripetano e io
ne so qualcosa
no no no non ho né di me non aspettare
cioè nel senso
capisco che tutti quelli megan fox e
strip club che credo sia megan fox anche
strip club è molto cercato ma ovviamente
megan fox megan fox strip club e ryanair
ryanair sicuro sicuro porca vacca 20
milioni di madonna in top 2 ryanair tra
ryanair e rihanna
rihanna non ci arriva cinquemila sono
tante e con tantissime però mica 20
milioni tra rihanna e la dieta migliore
l'aver rihanna per forza la dieta
migliore non interessa nessuno tutti
obesi tutti i grassi tranne me che son
magro il cazzo probabilità migliore
jackie chan jackie chan per forza cioè
dieta migliore veramente scarsissima
effetto jackie chan hom insurance jackie
chan hom insurance and charge il jazz
dai grazie charging tra churchill e
siria inizia a essere difficili dopo un
po perché più o meno sono siria siamo
tornati a nove se azzecco questa arrivo
a 10 tra siria e jennifer aniston ma
cosa ne so io come l'ho sbagliata due
volte alla fine facciamo quello che
penso al contrario io metterei jennifer
aniston
però ho sbagliato già due volte quindi
[Musica]
[ __ ] grande palco anche non ti si
caga più nessuno la pac man e lord of
the rings pac man
grande grandissimo signore degli anelli
e l'hotel di lusso che ovviamente prima
non si calava nessuno gli hotel a cinque
stelle è infatti non si caga nessuno gli
hotel di lusso sola 12 hotel di lusso e
dead c'eran tiger grande mi faccio
crescere la barba come teme la pittura
di rosso la seconda guerra mondiale e
gira ma chi cazzo ne frega di hitler e
sheeran vince grandissimo seconda guerra
mondiale clash clans clash of lance
track ratio kahn se la fame nel mondo
purtroppo e dico purtroppo sicuro e
clash of france et orbi tra hunger e
driving lesson drive inglese è uguale ma
perché vada buona va bene va bene come
driving e dyson cazzo è un dyson non ho
idea di che cosa sia la cosa cazzo è un
bacio 17 ragazzi da non arrivare a 10
non fatte 17 è un aspirapolvere va bene
il prodotto davvero molto bon unico
questo è solo motivo per cui momento
cinque stelle per il resto su chi sa
benissimo come non è particolare su chi
sa benissimo è consigliato su chi sa
benissimo e non è una 2000
sto scherzando sto scherzando ironia o
scherzando era per mettere in chiaro con
la roma deve 2000 erano in uno scherzo
scherzando mia cugina e del 2000 non mi
permetterei mai
sea haven chiavero cucina si ama ragazzi
questo era era una prova di conoscenza
di google santo iddio che poi alla fine
non era il più popolare ma il più
googlato che va beh più o meno però
capito vi sia piaciuto ragazzi cosa
sento se mi è piaciuta sull'argomento è
un mi piace un mi piace per la dyson ma
ne voglio miliardi sopra quello anche la
pace di facebook e cavani video come
descrizione sera si discute ci diamo
anche servito e ragazzi
[Musica]